hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll a
couple years ago a little more than a
couple years ago episode 86 of mindscape
we had Lord Martin Reese on the show
Martin is a very well-known and
respected theoretical astrophysicist but
he's also someone who worries about the
future of humanity so we were talking
about existential risks the prospects of
post-humanity stuff like that and
naturally we talked about one example
that was in the news not long before
which was the Large Hadron Collider the
giant particle accelerator in Geneva
which we don't remember now because it
didn't happen but people were worried at
the time about the chance that you would
make a tiny black hole or a new kind of
particle that would utterly destroy the
Earth and physicists of course worried
about this too they don't want to die
because they did some particle physics
experiment gone terribly wrong so they
thought about it they thought about it
really hard and they said as far as we
can tell the chances of this happening
are just incredibly incredibly tiny we
should just go ahead there were people
out there who said what do you mean
incredibly tiny how tiny does it have to
be if we're really talking about the end
of all life on Earth and Martin Reese
had an interesting rejoinder to that he
said well there's also a probability
that you will find a free energy source
that will completely remove our
dependence on foreign oil forever
this is very very unlikely to happen at
a particle accelerator like the LHC but
it's possible and his point was you know
once you're going into these tails of
distributions where things are super
super unlikely it's hard to say what
probabilities are and hard to judge them
his judgment was you should just go on
with something like the LHC I thought
that was an interesting argument but it
does beg some questions about how we
deal about huge terrible risks or even
how we deal about Minor risks when we're
facing a choice between basically a safe
bet versus something that might be okay
but has a chance of being really good or
a chance of being terribly bad how do we
reason about that choice rationally how
do we weigh the possible risk of things
going terribly wrong
so today's guest Lara butchak is a
philosopher at Princeton University and
she is the expert in the world on
exactly this problem she has a book
called risk and rationality where she
basically addresses some lingering
paradoxes in the theory of rational
choices in the theory of rational
choices it's all about I mean of course
if you have something that you value at
100 and something else you value at 50
then you're going to prefer the one you
prefer you're going to prefer the 100
over the 50 but when probabilities
become involved how do you risk or how
do you weigh rather 50 percent chance of
something you value 100 and 50 chance of
getting Zero versus a hundred percent
chance of getting something you value at
50. and of course there's a lot of
discussion in the rational Choice
literature about what it means to Value
something it's not just money you
certainly value the second million
dollars less than the first million
dollars that you might ever make that's
understood so that's okay but there's a
general feeling that there is some way
to assign value to things and then when
you're faced with a probability you just
take the expectation value you take the
average you multiply the reward times
the probability and that's how you
should weigh it and Lara's point is that
no you shouldn't
there is a separate thing to keep in
mind which is how risk averse you are so
her point is that it's not irrational to
either be super super averse to taking
risks or to not care that much it's not
something that you can subsume into a
rational Choice calculation it's a
separate thing to keep in mind people
have values for different things that
can happen they also have an aversion to
the worst possible thing happening that
is a risk aversion factor that it's okay
to introduce into your theory about how
to reason in cases of uncertainty
we're all faced with cases of
uncertainty all the time uh the LHC is
an example but where do you go for
dinner what job do you take who do you
go on a date with these are all things
where you're weighing probabilities
because you don't know exactly what's
going to happen so this kind of
reasoning this is philosophy that really
helps you in the real world in principle
so you'll see what some of the answers
are and you may disagree but that's the
risk you'll have to take let's go
foreign
[Music]
Laura bushack welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you thanks for having me I
have to ask you know when you tell
people that your professional expertise
is in rationality does this put like a
lot of pressure on you to never do
something silly like you know uh forget
your keys or things like that do you
feel like you have to be the most
rational person at all times yeah
exactly and in fact when I tell people
my specialty is decision Theory people
who know me laugh because I'm terrible
at making quick decisions
and in fact there's this joke that um
that people study the thing they're bad
at so you know other people knew how to
make decisions so they didn't have to
study it I had to get a PhD and I still
don't know yeah I mean famously moral
and ethical philosophers are not always
the most moral and ethical people right
we we hope but there's no real
correlation there
that's right yep so what do we mean by
rationality like I think that there's a
technical sense that you probably have
in mind that might be a little bit
different than the person on the street
has in mind when you say something like
that yeah good so there's two things two
different senses of the word rationality
even in philosophy and one is just a
purely
consistency uh so you can think of it by
analogy to logical consistency if you
believe p and you believe P implies q
but you don't believe Q you're
irrational
purely in the sense of being
inconsistent regardless of what the
content of p and Q is
um so that's the kind of rationality
decision theorist study the other kind
of rationality we might call substantive
rationality
um and an example of that is you know if
you believe that aliens have invaded
your body that might be perfectly
consistent but
um we think that's not a good belief to
have
doesn't match the evidence or something
like this that's that last one is on the
one hand sounds more I don't say more
important but at least closer to the
average person's thought about what
rationality is but at the same time
maybe a little bit Lucy or Goosey I mean
do we have quite as rigorous a
definition of what that means uh we
certainly don't have a rigorous formal
definition yeah of what that means
so and you are you studying mostly the
first part the nice logical
philosophical part yep
so the first part and um
you know maybe it seems a little bit far
removed from what we initially care
about but if you sort of think about
to sit consistency and decision making
the big question is if you already know
what you want
and you know how likely various things
are to happen
then what should you do and that's
really a question of being consistent
with your beliefs and desires so in that
when described that way I hope it sounds
like something that most people are in
fact interested in they want to know I
like these things what should I do about
that rather than which things to like I
can't help tell you which things to like
unfortunately uh it almost sounds like
something where if you don't think about
it too hard it you might get the idea
that no one should disagree about this I
mean is there is there a minority school
of thought saying we should be
inconsistent and irrational all the time
or
maybe a very small minority but we don't
don't actually know who they are no in
fact everybody thinks we should be
consistent but the real debate is about
what consistency means right okay and
you also mentioned decision Theory which
is that the same is that a subset of
being rational or is that like a
neighbor
yeah so we can have rationality in a
number of different areas there could be
rationality in what you believe
rationality and what you desire decision
theory is about rationality in uh what
you choose or what you prefer
um and really it's about rationality in
what you choose or prefer when you're in
a condition of risk or uncertainty so
when you don't know what the world is
like
which is most of the time which is most
okay so that is the tricky part and you
know I've talked to people like Julia
gallif on the podcast the people who are
sort of you know professional
rationality uh boosters but not within
Academia quite and they talk a lot about
Bayesian Theory theorizing and updating
on evidence and things like that does
that come in also to uh either the
rationality part of the decision theory
part yep yeah so one part of decision
Theory so decision Theory involves at
the very least probabilities which
measure How likely you think various
things are to happen and utilities which
roughly measure how much you like
various things and so the Bayesian
updating
um that all falls into the probabilities
side so one thing we have to know before
we make a decision is
um what should my probabilities be and
especially given the evidence or how and
how should my probabilities respond to
evidence so that's part of decision
Theory that's not the part where I've
um
where I've argued for something that's
that's different from the mainstream
and I guess you know still laying the
groundwork a little bit here how
concerned is a philosopher like yourself
with the reality of human psychology
like are you trying to describe how
rational people actually behave or are
you content to just think like this is
how you should behave if you were
rational I don't know how people
actually behave
well I'm I'm
trying to describe how people should
behave but how people actually behave is
relevant because if we've sort of if
people behave very differently from the
theory and we don't have a good
explanation for that then we're going to
want to investigate whether the theory
is actually correct in that place
that sounds like remarkably like science
rather than philosophy wow well there
are maybe Navy Co extensive
I'm happy to believe that myself but so
yeah so in particular we might imagine
that the armchair thinking about
rationality leads us to a certain
picture and then we notice people not
behaving that way and then we go oh
actually we made a mistake we can be
better at describing what it means to be
rational
yeah or at least we need to but how
people behave isn't relevant
direct isn't directly relevant to what
rationality is it's just sort of like a
datum and we either have to say oh
that's a way in which people behave
irrationally and here's why that's
irrational or we have to incorporate it
into our Theory so we won't know which
thing to do until we investigate further
I mean is there any guidance other than
consistency to what we would eventually
dubbed to be rational
uh not in decision Theory but
consistency turns out to be a pretty
difficult notion
um to say what it means and it actually
turns out to have a lot of content so
consistency really
um dictates what you should do pretty
strongly okay that's very interesting
all right so let's let's get into the
meat of it then a little bit
um it might seem once again if you were
very naive you would say what's so hard
I prefer a to B I'm going to do a that's
my decision Theory but where where it
becomes interesting is when
uncertainties come into the game as you
already mentioned exactly
so how does that happen what how do we
think in conditions of uncertainty well
ston B and B
and be sure or do I want to have some
chance of a but some chance of C which
of those two things is better and just
knowing how much I like a b and c isn't
going to tell me which of those two
choices I should make so what do we do
so what do we do well first of all we
have to
um we have to know or estimate the
probabilities of A and C so for example
maybe I'm let's let's put some numbers
on this
um maybe I'm I like a hundred dollars
more than I like fifty dollars more than
I like zero dollars so I want to decide
between just getting fifty dollars or
taking a coin flip of a fair coin
between a hundred dollars and zero
dollars
um
so
uh yeah and so what should I do well
um the first step is to figure out what
decision theorists call my utilities
that's how much I like the various
amounts of money
the way that we typically do that is to
um reverse engineer them from your
preferences so I know lots of your
preferences over lots of a lot of
different things from those preferences
maybe I discover that your utility
function is linear in money so you
um
think fifty dollars is uh better than
zero dollars by as much as you think a
hundred dollars is better than fifty
dollars good
um now according to the standard Theory
the one that I argue against in my book
that's actually all the information we
need once we have your utilities and
your probabilities we can figure out
exactly what to do so uh we
so on the standard Theory you should
maximize expected utility or average
utility so the value of
a gamble that has a 50 chance of giving
you a hundred utility and a 50 chance of
giving you zero utility is just going to
be 50.
uh multiply 0.5 by 100 multiply 0.5 by
zero add them together and the utility
of just a straightforward fifty dollars
is going to be 50. uh so according to
expected utility Theory you have to be
indifferent between those two choices
at least given that your utility
function is linear now if you're not
indifferent
the expected utility theorist is going
to say well then your utility function
isn't what we thought it was right and
so in particular many people would have
utility function that has less utility
for the second fifty dollars than for
the first that's
that's as most people do then the
explanation according to the expected
utility theorist has to be exactly what
you said that I like the first fifty
dollars more than I like the second
fifty dollars which means on average
that coin flip will have less utility
but the idea is that even if that's true
even if you'd rather have fifty dollars
than a 50 50 chance of zero or a hundred
that's no worries for expected utility
Theory because it's just that utility is
not the same as money and we can still
have something called utility that's
right that's right
is that true like we're not even getting
into your stuff yet but uh I've always
felt a little bit nervous at the idea
that there's something called utility
that is a number that we can just attach
to different outcomes I know that maybe
we can reverse engineer such a thing but
how how is that an innocent move or is
that fraud apparel
uh yeah great question well there are
maybe two moves there and one is the
move that we can have a number that we
reverse engineer from your preferences
that describes how much you like
something that's different from your
money the second number the second move
that people often make is something like
and utility doesn't describe anything in
the head or in the world it's simply a
representation of your preferences so
it's meaningless in itself
um so I tend to think
the first move is innocuous it does it
describes something
pretty intuitive right so like
um
how much I like money depends on how
much money I already have that's like a
pretty good uh it's pretty good we want
to be able to capture that with our
theory of decision making maybe which
coin flips a millionaire takes uh or is
going to be different from which coin
flips
um someone in poverty takes uh so that
seems innocuous
um the other move and then saying well
we don't need utility to describe
anything in the head or we don't need
the numbers to sort of fit intuitively
with what you think your utility
function might be
uh maybe that's a little bit less
innocuous so that so that kind of move
would say Okay Sean you prefer the fifty
dollars to the coin flip you think you
don't like additional dollars any less
the more money you have
um but as it turns out your utility
function says otherwise so you're really
bad at figuring out what your utility
function is
right I mean maybe maybe you just
answered the question I wanted to ask
but let me ask it anyway in case there's
another angle here which is
I worry about the circularity of it like
if I already had perfectly rational
preferences then I could imagine I could
reverse engineer a utility function to
represent them but in some sense you're
defining what it means to have perfectly
rational preferences by I'm always going
for the thing that has greater utility
so if real people don't have perfectly
consistent preferences what do we do how
do we even talk about this good yeah
good that's I mean that's a great
question and it's it's a question that's
received a lot of attention
um
an answer you don't want to give is that
unless someone is perfectly rational
they don't have a utility function at
all okay but our Theory would be pretty
useless right
um some of my best friends are pretty
irrational so yeah
but they still like things right so we
want to still say they have a utility
function so
um I think a better answer
is that often many of your preferences
or many of your central preferences are
pretty consistent
um and you do have maybe good access to
your central preferences and then we can
figure out what your more complicated
preferences should be from them for
example maybe if I ask you about a bunch
of coin flips between dollar amounts
maybe that's something you have pretty
good access to and can tell me about and
then I can figure out your utility
function from that and then I can then
use your utility function when I advise
you how to play poker or how to invest
in the stock market because those are
much more complicated decisions that you
don't have any intuitive preferences
about so I kind of like to think of it
as there's this first step of
determining your utility function from a
smaller subset of your preferences okay
ones that you're pretty sure about and
if those are inconsistent
maybe you can figure out which ones you
want to keep and which ones you want to
jettison
um and then Second Step tell you what to
do in these more complicated actual
decisions
okay that makes sense because that's
related to what I was going to worry
about like whether or not people even
implicitly actually do anything like
this and and maybe what you're saying is
they they do something close to it for
the big important straightforward
decisions and then that implies a
certain way they should be acting
rationally in The Fringe cases even if
maybe they're not as good at that yeah
that's exactly right yeah
and I also don't want to say I mean I
don't think people have
anything as precise as the utility and
probability numbers that we use in the
theory
but I still think the theories are
useful because they can tell us
things in Broad brush so maybe we
shouldn't use the theory to distinguish
between how you feel about a coin flip
with a 60 chance of heads and a coin
flip with a 61 chance of heads okay
maybe you don't actually have any any
feelings about those two things that are
different from each other but if we can
sort of in general
lessons from the theory like here's a
lesson on the classical theory if you
are an expected utility maximizer then
you're always going to want to make
decisions on the basis of more
information rather than less like that's
a pretty okay
simple principle that we have to do this
complicated math to discover
um but the theory is sort of useful for
giving us insights like that even in
cases where the um the complexity of the
theory outruns the actual complexity of
our heads I know that in some
circumstances in some contexts people
will make a lot of a big deal about the
fact that human beings are bounded in
their rationality and therefore we
satisfy instead of optimize satisficing
being some weird combination of
satisfying and uh uh what is the rest of
satisfice made out of oh uh
I forget
the word anyway but like we do good if
then we stop because it would take a lot
of five but Matthew yeah exactly but
well yeah but uh but so is that part of
the being a decision theorist or a
rationality theorist game that the real
people like don't do all this
complicated math but they kind of
approximate it in some way so yeah so
the ultimately decision theory is about
what's rational to do or what's rational
to prefer but it doesn't need to be
about what's the best method to use to
make decisions so even if we think
expected utility maximization is the
Right theory of rationality
uh it might be the case that you
nonetheless shouldn't use it in a lot of
decisions for example a car is coming at
you you need to Swerve to the left or
the right if you bothered to calculate
the expected utilities it would take too
long and you just get hit by the car
right so it's like not a good
decision-making method in all
circumstances so there's a separate
question of what are the best rules or
heuristics that are going to help us
approximate ideal rationality is it
analogous to the issue in political
theory about ideal Theory versus sort of
real world stuff like we can imagine
what the perfect Society is and then
move toward it but then other people are
saying it's not even worth Imagining the
ideal Society because our minds might
change along the way
yeah that's that's one analogy
um but decision theorists really are
interested in ideal rationality yeah
first and foremost I think maybe a
different analogy is the Paradox of
Hedonism so if you're a utilitarian you
think that
um
or a hedonist you think that the best
moral actions are the ones that produce
the most pleasure in the world right
um nonetheless that wouldn't be a very
good method for making decisions about
what to do you wouldn't say oh hello
person let's be friends because my being
friends with you would maximize the
amount of pleasure in the world that
would be a method to not be friends and
then therefore not have a lot of
pleasure in the world
um
so instead there's just going to be a
separate evaluation of what is good in
this case Okay uh what brings about the
most pleasure in the world and how to
actually
behave or think or live your life
to meet that ideal standard okay and
similarly in decision Theory there's one
question
um
what do rational decision makers choose
and another question how do they go
about choosing it okay fair enough and I
guess there's just a couple more minor
points to get on the table here before
we get into risk which is the other fun
part of what you're thinking about
um we use the word utility
but this is personal decision making
it's not necessarily connected to
utilitarianism which imagines that we
can sort of add up people's utilities
yeah
that's right so um the word utility in
decision theory has come to mean just
whatever it is you care about so you can
still be maximizing your utility your
own personal utility even if you're
perfectly altruistic okay the the
decision theorist would just say oh
Sean's utility function
um assigns
higher utility to things that are good
for other people and lower utility to
things that are bad for other people so
it's very flexible in that way I mean do
do people ever claim there's got to be
some philosopher out there who makes
every possible claim right are there
claims that there are situations where
people are acting apparently rationally
that simply cannot be modeled by
attaching utility function to them
so in order to attach a utility function
to someone we're gonna need to we're
going to need the utility function to
have certain properties
um and if it doesn't have those
properties then we can't so one example
might be
um if you assign infinite utility to
something then that's not going to
we're not going to at least be able to
maximize
expected utility or average utility so
that's like might be an example that's
perfectly rational to care only about
this one thing so that it's infinitely
valuable
um and yet that can't be captured by
expected utility although I suppose
that's still a case of wanting to
maximize utility yeah and also as soon
as you start talking about Infinity I
think that you probably this is not a
realistic kind of thing yeah I can't
place the infinitility on anything at
all but I guess okay the other footnote
is we talked about how maybe the second
fifty dollars is less valuable to you
than the first fifty dollars but there's
nothing in the formalism that prevents a
person from being risk seeking right
like they would rather have the 50 50
chance uh of a hundred dollars than a
sure thing of 50 right that's perfectly
okay yep that's right
you can prefer anything you want as long
as you're consistent and is there
psychological data about where people
usually fall
well people tend to be risk averse when
it comes to buying insurance so you're
you know you're say you have a one in a
hundred chance of a fire in your house
you'll pay more for that insurance than
is one in a hundred the cost of your
house
um and people tend to be risk seeking
when buying lottery tickets okay so
there's a lottery that has like a one in
a million chance of winning a million
dollars you might nonetheless pay more
than a dollar for that Lottery
I guess that yeah that's a great example
I'm kind of ashamed I didn't think of
that so playing the lottery or many
other games in Vegas or whatever are
examples where we purposefully take
risks even though the expected payoff in
dollar terms is less than what we're
paying for the for the right to take the
risk that's right yeah that's right
do we ever have the uh you know
professional rationality conference in
Las Vegas has that ever happened have we
seen those the philosophers go play the
slot machines
there was a there was an APA Once An
American philosophical Association in
Las Vegas and you know as a decision
theorist you look at those slot machines
they just look like trash cans for money
good so there is an example where the
philosophers are doing well at their at
their particular area of expertise okay
so the the risky business as it were is
the important thing here right
um you I think you said it once but
let's let's say it again if I get it
right in expected utility Theory all you
need to know to decide what is the
irrational choice is what are the
utilities of different outcomes and what
are the probabilities of those outcomes
happening right that's right
and you would like to say that uh well
actually let me first ask are we any
good at really evaluating probabilities
uh the examples are always like flipping
coins and going to Vegas or whatever but
if it's like real world things should I
take this job or something like that uh
yeah that sounds hard
yeah it's pretty hard
[Laughter]
things like we're pretty good at you
know we get weather forecasts they're
usually pretty specific 30 chance of
rain
um we're pretty good in those cases
where there are possible experts that
can
tell us things and usually their
phenomena that behave pretty regularly
like
um you know like weather or cards or you
know maybe the stock market doesn't
behave super regularly but uh a little
more regularly than uh my job prospects
behave or something like that
okay so then but but your your big
argument in the book and elsewhere is
that maybe this minimal
set of ingredients of knowing what all
the options are with their utilities and
the probabilities of them happening is
not all that we can or should take into
account
um and the examples from your book I
know uh I had a friend you know notice
that I was reading your book and picked
it up and like oh this is very Tactical
some of the examples get very uh
complicated but is there a simple way to
ease Us in to this discussion yeah yeah
so
yeah so you might put more weight on
worst case scenarios than better case
scenarios
uh in the sense that you might
um whatever happens in worst case
scenarios might like play a much larger
role in your decision making than what
happens in best case scenarios
if you do that then there isn't going to
be a utility function and a probability
function that can capture your decision
making so the so expected utility theory
is going to say you're irrational
okay you want to talk about some
examples we got to do some examples
because I would I would think when you
say that well isn't isn't it saying that
we worry about the worst possible
outcome just this to say that we put a
big negative utility on the worst
possible outcome so if we did that in
one decision then that's what expected
utility could say but if in every
decision you care more about the worst
case then the best case there isn't
going to be a utility function that can
capture you okay okay good so maybe an
example would help make that clear okay
um so there are two examples I like
um one is called the Olay Paradox maybe
we could talk about both of them and see
if you find either of them compelling
great um Okay so
may I ask you Sean for some of your
preferences please okay so uh here's two
gambles you can have either one the
first gamble a ten percent chance of
five million dollars
and the second Gamble and a an 11 chance
of one million dollars
I'll take the 10 chance of five million
dollars take the 10 chance of five
million dollars wait sorry yeah so say
say it again because we do make sure
yeah uh that was so a 10 chance
for an 11 chance of a million dollars
yeah I'm just gonna be the rational
person and take a 10 chance of five
minutes most people share your practice
Yeah I'm not weird that way yeah okay
here's the second
um second option second choice forget
that first choice now this one is
slightly more complicated so you might
have to I might write it down yeah yeah
write it down Okay so
an 89 chance of a million dollars
and a 10 chance of 5 million dollars and
a one percent chance of nothing
so that's like an entire gamble one
percent chance of nothing 89 chance of a
million dollars ten percent chance of
five million so probably I'm gonna get a
dollar maybe I'll get five dollars tiny
chance I'll get nothing
millions of dollars these are millions
of dollars millions of dollars does it
matter does it do the units matter
um well actually that's an interesting
question it is yeah okay yeah we could
think about that but uh millions of
dollars good yeah okay so that's one
option
second option uh a million dollars for
sure okay
so which of those two would you rather
have that complicated gamble that's
probably going to get you a million
dollars
has a one percent chance of getting you
nothing
and a somewhat chance of getting you
five million dollars or would you rather
me just give you a million dollars
so just to talk it through I mean I
think the answer is I would like the
first one better and I think that's
probably the answer you want me to give
but
um you don't care you're not this is not
a normative discussion uh but I just
want to get to know you better yeah
that's all that's this is yeah this is a
weird dating site uh asking people about
their rational preferences under
conditions of risk so so the first
option says again most likely a million
dollars but a non-neglible chance of
five million dollars and a tiny chance
that I get nothing at all versus 100
chance of a million dollars and I think
that the reasoning would be that I'm
willing to risk the one percent chance
of nothing to get the 10 chance of 5
million yes
so that's your your actual preference
yeah you'd rather have that one I'd
rather have the first option with 89 and
one yeah okay well most people uh would
rather have the second option really
most people would rather just have a
million dollars than to risk getting
nothing in exchange for maybe getting
five million dollars
so just to make it just to you know I'm
gonna keep saying it out loud so
everyone follows along so in the in the
mixed probability one there is a 99
chance that I get at least a million
dollars and and within that there's a
some chance it's five million and I'm
risking the one percent chance of
getting nothing and I do know as someone
who's played poker that one percent
chances do happen so I'm not my
reasoning is not that one percent equal
zero because that certainly false but I
think I'd be willing to take that much
risk
um okay yeah
okay well that's interesting most people
are unlike you okay in that respect
um and so your preferences actually can
be captured by expected utility
maximization okay but if you have the
standard preference
um here's sort of how the reasoning goes
if I'm choosing between
a 10 chance and a five of five million
dollars and an 11 chance of one million
dollars that first choice I gave you
um I will I'll like probably get nothing
the minimum value of that is nothing uh
so close whether I'll get five million
or one million so go for the bigger
option
um but in the second choice I gave you
one of the options
gave me a million dollars no matter what
right
the worst I can do in that gamble is get
a million dollars and so if you're the
kind of person that weighs worse cases
heavily you don't even have to weigh
them that heavily you just have to weigh
them sort of more than you weigh best
cases than your
um expected utility maximization isn't
going to be able to capture you because
there's no utility function that allows
for that pattern of preference good so
maybe said in another way there is a
rational way of Behaving under which the
introduction of even a tiny chance of a
super bad outcome is very very heavily
in your decision process yeah yep that's
right that's right and um and by the way
you mentioned poker and I just want to
point out that your reasoning in poker
might be a little it maybe it should be
a little different in this case than in
poker because when I play poker I'm
going to be playing a lot of hands so
whatever losses I make are going to be
made up by gains on it if I just pick
the thing that does best on average on
the other hand if I'm just going to make
a choice once like these gambles I'm
only going to offer you them to you once
say
um or the choice of which job to go for
the choice of who to marry
um we can't employ the reasoning that
says look if this were to be repeated
many times I'd do better on average by
taking this thing because it's not going
to be repeated many times I think it's a
very very good point and um even even
within poker there's a difference
between playing just at a table versus
playing in a tournament right because
playing at a table for exactly the
reasons you just said you in every hand
want to maximize your expected return
but that strategy might not
it maximize the chance that you win a
tournament because if you bust out you
can't win right you can't climb back in
all right yeah yeah
yeah and I also I I appreciate the idea
that if uh I would be given these two
options and I got unlucky and I had to
come home and tell my spouse that uh I
just won zero dollars even though I
could have won a million dollars that
would be a difficult conversation to
have a difficult conversation to have
yeah
which is why this is a really good
dating question
make sure you're compatible about these
kinds of things exactly
um okay can I give you one more example
please yeah okay so um and the away
Paradox that's the example I just
mentioned that involved large amounts of
money and small probabilities so we
might think maybe people are getting
confused by the big numbers or something
so here's an example that doesn't
involve
um large amount of uh doesn't involve
values like that and this is an example
due to Matthew Rabin
um so let me just ask you
um
I'm just gonna give you a coin flip
between
losing a hundred dollars and gaining a
hundred ten dollars okay do you want
that coin flip or not
uh no no okay most people don't want
that coin flip
um now let me offer you a coin flip
between
losing a thousand dollars
and gaining six million dollars
I'll take that one you'll take that one
but most people would
um in fact this is another example of a
preference that expected utility can't
handle really and the basic idea yeah
the basic idea is that
if you don't like that initial coin flip
between losing a hundred dollars and
gaining 110 then
if you're an expected utility maximizer
your utility function has to be pretty
concave it has to say you like a hundred
and ten dollars less than losing than
the you know you like the
the interval between 110 and zero that
that matters less than the interval
between zero and negative 100 and if
your utility function is already that
concave in that low amounts of money
then once you get to losing a thousand
dollars
that's actually going to be more
valuable than gaining any amount of
money whatsoever so the point is if we
start in order to explain these
um a small amount of risk aversion in
low numbers we have to imply an
implausibly large amount of risk
aversion in large numbers so this sounds
like a result that is a little mathy and
maybe you're hiding some of the math
from us but we'll trust you that that is
the result but the I mean I bet I could
wriggle out of it if you gave me
arbitrary freedom in my utility function
and presumably by utility function you
mean I'm assigning different amounts of
utility to these gains and losses in
money the only restriction on your
utility function is that it has to
um
it has to be well using a math math term
everywhere differentiable it's a piece
basically it has to be smooth really
that's all yeah yeah
so you and and the sort of like
intuitive idea is that if you
uh
if you don't like this initial coin flip
it has just a little bit of gain a
little bit more gain than loss
then you really
don't value
positive amounts of money very much
but but I'm surprised that I'm I'm not
allowed to not value 110 very much but
value six million dollars a lot
um right well so uh oh sorry I guess the
uh the other the assumption is that it's
your utility function is going to be
concave
so if you had a utility function that
was um
you know increase very slightly up to a
hundred thousand dollars and then like
shot at the air then um you'd be allowed
to do that okay good all right yeah so
that we might think if we sort of asked
you and and the actual result is that
um you don't like this coin flip
regardless of your initial wealth level
[Music]
um then you don't like the losing a
thousand dollars gaining any amount of
money whatsoever at your okay so this is
so this seems to be even more vividly
than the first one
um uh as you said a real challenge for
expected utility Theory so just to just
to say it once again uh given the choice
between losing 100 and gaining 110 on a
coin flip most people will not want the
coin flip at all because it's barely a
difference and you don't want to lose a
hundred dollars given the coin flip
between losing a thousand and gaining
six million most people would willingly
take the risk of losing a thousand
that's right uh to gain the Six Million
at a 50 chance but there is no way to
accommodate that within expected utility
there's some under certain reasonable
assumptions yeah that's right
um and
cat example just because of course it's
all a lot of them are pretty
mathematical this is an example
that is just supposed to illustrate that
there are two different psychological
phenomena okay so maybe we want to
capture them in our theory of
rationality
um Okay so
you really like coffee in fact
um if you sort of think about it you
think I like the second cup just as much
as the first I like the third cup just
as much as the second the fourth cup
just as much as the third you're a
coffee addict
um
I on the other hand
can't tolerate that much coffee once
I've had one cup I don't want another
cup
um
now you and I so you and I have
different attitudes towards coffee but
we also have different attitudes towards
gambles
so for you you think uh the possibility
of not doing so well
is not going to make up for the
possibility of doing pretty well so you
way ways worst case scenarios really
heavily okay me on the other hand I
weigh all scenarios the same
um so let's think about each of our
preferences between one cup of coffee on
the one hand and a coin flip between no
cups of coffee and two cups of coffee
sure well I don't want any more than one
cup so I'm gonna take one cup of coffee
guaranteed yeah um you like each cup
just as much as the last
but you don't like taking risks you
weigh the possibility of not getting
anything uh more heavily than the
possibility of getting the two cups so
you also prefer one cup of coffee now
because we have the same preferences
expected utility theory is going to have
to say we have the same utility
functions
um but there are two really different
psychological explanations for why we
chose why we did why we chose how we did
um and you might think we'd like a
theory that captures the differences
between our two preferences
I would like that theory so what is that
theory
you maximize a weighted average where if
you give more weight to the bottom
portion of your probability distribution
than the top portion you're you I I call
you risk avoidant and if you give more
weight to what goes on at the top
portion I call you risk inclined
so in other words in addition to just
having utilities for different outcomes
and probabilities of getting them we
also each have a risk aversion curve
exactly right and it's it's uh convex if
your risk averse so as you're thinking
about what happens in worse and worse
cases you care about it more and more
and it's concave in the case of uh risk
it risk inclination so as you're
thinking about what happens in better
and better scenarios you care about them
proportionally more and more okay and
and you don't care they're both very uh
you can fit them both into the theory
that's exactly right and I think both
people are behaving fully rationally
right I guess so that's the big thing so
there might be other people philosophers
who remain nameless I guess uh who will
say no these people who aren't following
what we think are their utility
functions are just irrational
and you're saying that no they just have
different attitudes towards risk but
under the idea that being rational is
just being consistent in your
preferences they're still perfectly
rational
that's exactly right
okay good and uh so what is the I mean
maybe maybe put some more meat on these
bones can you apply that idea to the
examples or some of the examples that
we're doing uh
sure so in the example of
uh the first example with the million
dollars and the five million dollars
right um
you are the standard person not you
because you didn't have the standard
preferences but the standard person
um assigns more weight to the bottom one
percent of the distribution right than
the top one percent of the distribution
so the fact that you might get zero
dollars is
um
that gets weight maybe uh you know
0.2 instead of or sorry 0.02 instead of
0.01
um
in the example with the coin flips
you
uh maybe most people would
assign weight
three quarters to the bottom to the
worst option and one quarter to the
better option given that they both have
a 50 chance of happening right so even
if you had a linear utility function
um if you're assigning weight three
quarters to losing a hundred dollars and
wait one quarter to gaining a hundred
and ten dollars that's gonna work out to
be a negative number so less than zero
I.E doing nothing okay good and then in
the coffee cup example uh your my
YouTube your utility function of coffee
cups was maybe uh utility of X coffee
cups equals x my utility function of
coffee cups was maybe uh utility utility
of zero coffee cups equals zero utility
of one or more coffee cups equals one
um my risk function was linear so all
uh States get weight equal to their
probabilities whereas your risk function
assigned you know maybe uh two-thirds
weight to the
bottom 50 of the distribution
okay I think I am seeing it let me let
me uh let me modify the example of the
uh one million five million nothing
because I think it
maybe this is not a realistic choice but
I think it it shows it makes me it helps
me understand why a typical expected
utility person would get in trouble with
this I could easily imagine if you said
there's a coin flip
uh and you get either nothing or let's
say
20 million dollars
coin flip between nothing and 20 million
dollars or guaranteed one million
dollars I think I would take the one
million dollars guaranteed because I am
at risk averse even though because it's
not even about risk aversion in that
case it's about my utility function
right like the right the 20 million
dollars is not as valuable but if you
said to me 98 chance of a million
one percent chance of nothing and one
percent chance of 20 million I might
prefer that to a guaranteed million
because my my thought process would be
like you know probably I'm getting a
million but I kind of like the idea of
having a a little bit of a chance of
getting 20 million dollars and so
basically it's exactly the same
comparison
but with an extra 98 chance of of a
million dollars guaranteed and so if I
if I do prefer one example
then I should I should be consistent in
my preferences according to expected
utility and I'm not allowed according to
expected utility Theory to just accept
the chance of a loss because I like the
thrilling chance of a one percent huge
gain but not have the same thing when
it's 50 50. that's exactly right yeah
that's exactly right
um and the preference you just described
yourself as having
is a risk inclined preference right by
the way so you you care more about what
happens at the top one percent of the
distribution than at the bottom one
percent of the distribution but that's
compatible with me if I were just given
50 chance of nothing 50 chance of 20
million not preferring that to 100
chance of one million
that's right on my view on your view
okay yeah yeah good yeah that's right so
I guess as a physicist
um I would worry that there's a that
there's a curve fitting going on here
you've added a whole new parameter to
our model of rationality so you're able
to fit more circumstances but you know
there's a famous line about how if you
give me five parameters I can fit an
elephant or something like that I mean
is there is there a worry that we're
just giving people too much Freedom or
is that just the real world we're just
being realistic well this is
why for me it's important to
um
really try to figure out what we're
capturing with these parameters so yeah
you're absolutely right if you gave me
like more parameters I capture more
preferences great but what I'm
interested in is whether these
parameters
sort of
capture
what it is to reason instrumentally
which means reason about taking the
means to your ends
um and I think that choice involves
not just taking an average that's one
way you might reason
um you might take the means to your ends
but importantly uh
it's actually open to you what to do
it's open to you
how much weight to put on worst cases or
better cases okay
um yeah so it's in that sense
data fitting
isn't the ultimate standard here uh
including because
were allowing it might be that people
are irrational so this is a theory of
rationality it's probably not going to
fit the data so our our data here so so
to speak is more
philosophers data about what we should
and to shouldn't be allowed to prefer
and what we what could count as
um
reasoning or preferences that are uh
taking the means to your ends okay and
maybe like another
way to think about it
um if we're if it's maybe hard to
conceptualize probabilities you can
instead think about
um each possible state of the world as
representing one of your future possible
selves it's like there are a hundred
future possible Sean's
um what would you rather giving all the
future were possible Sean's a million
dollars or giving 98 of them a million
dollars and giving one of them nothing
and one of them 20 million dollars uh so
it's and and
whereas the expected utility theorist
will say
um
there's a unique answer to that question
about how how sean should value his
future possible shots you should give
them all equal weight right in decision
making I say no actually it's up to you
if you want to put more weight on how
things go for worst off possible Sean
that's a reasonable way to take the
means to your ends that's a reasonable
way to sort of like cash out the maxim
of I'm trying to get what I want
um on the other hand if you as I guess
you do put a lot of weight on best off
future possible Sean that's also a
reasonable thing to do
um in either case you know you only have
one life to live only one of these guys
is going to be actual Sean so it's up to
you to to
um yeah to think about how much weight
to put on each of their interests
knowing that only one of them will be
actual you know I uh
it only now Dawns on me this is very
embarrassing but I have to think about
this in the context of the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which I'm kind of a proponent of so the
whole point of many worlds is that what
we think of as probabilities really are
actualities well Quantum probabilities
not every old probabilities but if we if
we did our choice making via some
Quantum random number generator then uh
yeah I've always taken the line this
might be a life-changing moment for me
because I've always taken the line that
it doesn't there's no difference in how
we think ethically or morally in many
worlds versus just a truly sarcastic
single world but you're saying well
my attitude towards risk aversion could
in principle change that
yeah that might be right yeah so if you
think
if you think all possible Sean's are
actual Sean's that's the view right then
um actually you're facing the problem of
distributed justice so you should decide
um as you might decide or it's plausible
that you should decide as you might
decide when you're just thinking about
how much to weigh the interests of each
of a hundred people
and we have a similar question in that
space should I care about the average
person how things go on average or
should I give more weight to the people
that are worse off in virtue of the fact
that they're the worst off right and if
you think the latter thing and you have
the interpretation physics
interpretation you just explained then
maybe you should be risk avoidant ah all
right I'm gonna have to think about this
we had to sleep on this before I
actually uh have an epiphany here but I
was just actually I don't know if you're
on Twitter but I was just actually
arguing with David Papineau on Twitter
about exactly this because he was trying
to say that there is there are moral
implications of many worlds and I was
trying to say no there's not so I might
have to back yeah well there is one and
can I mentioned there is one difference
between the case that maybe if you don't
want to rethink your entire life uh you
might be happy to hear about uh so in
the case of you
Distributing over all the possible
Sean's they're all you so you might
think that you're allowed to follow a
different ethical principle when they're
all you
then you are when they're all strangers
yeah but I think that to be consistent
in many worlds uh they're all future
versions of me but once they come into
existence they're all separate people I
see okay I see yeah they have to be
treated separately you reject the idea
that
difference okay well then um I know yeah
you might just have to up the creek
well all of the words that you have been
saying right now I mean we're we're
it's clear there's a relationship here
between a slightly different context
which is some kind of rawlsian theory of
Justice right so John Rawls famously
imagines that we try to put ourselves in
an original position where we don't know
who we are in the world and ask how
should we arrange the world in the way
that we'd be happiest with and and he
ends up with a very what might be called
a very risk-averse suggestion that we
want to arrange things to the benefit of
the worst off people so is that a real
connection or is that just a rhetorical
similarity that is a real connection so
um
there are actually two people writing in
this area who ended up with different
views and one is John Rawls and one is
John harsanyi so they both agree that
um when we're thinking about what's best
for Society for example Take A Simple
Choice
um
should everybody have fifty dollars or
should half our people have nothing and
half our people have a hundred dollars
right
um
they both thought making that decision
is the same as making the decision which
would which society would you rather
live in if you didn't know ahead of time
who you were going to be
but they had really different views
about what how you would make the
decision so harsani thought well you
assign equal probability to being each
person
and you maximize expected utility
therefore both the societies are equally
good you're indifferent between being an
arbitrary member of each Society
therefore each Society is
um just as good as the other roles on
the other hand thought
I can't assign probabilities to my being
any particular person in this society
and when I can't assign probabilities I
use a maximally risk-averse or
pessimistic or ambiguity averse rule
namely I pick the society or I pick the
choice with the highest minimum I Maxim
in therefore he would rather live in the
society he would rather be an arbitrary
member of the society in which everyone
got fifty dollars so he thinks that's
the moral choice now if you'll notice
that's a really really uh risk-averse
view that's one that cares only about
the worst off person right right the
second worst off person we don't care
about how things go for him at all in
terms of our society that might be like
caring only about the poor not giving
any and any weight whatsoever to the
middle class
um that doesn't seem good that seems
like way too concerned with one part of
the distribution and harsanya on the
other hand who uh derives that we should
care about the average member of society
that's not sensitive to how our utility
is distributed as all you might think
that's really bad
um it would mean a society and with
really poorly off people and really well
off people is just as good as a society
in which everybody's sort of in the
middle
um my view allows for an intermediate
position okay between these two guys
um because I think
in the original position if I don't know
which member I'm of society I'm going to
be I should use a risk avoidant decision
Theory so I should give more weight
to worst case scenarios but not
exclusive weight to worst case scenarios
so maybe if there are just three people
in my Society the worst guy the middle
guy and the best off guy I should give I
don't know weight uh wait two-thirds to
the worst off guy wait just slightly
less than one third to the middle off
guy and just a little bit of weight to
the best off Guy this is going to have
the result that I care a lot about
how get things go for the worst off but
still about how things go for the um you
know the second worse off so like should
care a lot about the poor but should
also care significantly about the middle
class and even we should care a little
bit about the very rich though
um much less than we should care about
the other classes so I think this is a
really good result I think it fits with
how many of us in fact think about the
morality of Distributing resources
across society and I think it allows us
to give an answer that sort of sensitive
both to the total amount of wealth in a
society
but also to how it's distributed
and kind of compatible with the idea
that at the personal utility level uh uh
I I would rank one billion dollars more
than 50 50 chance of two billion dollars
versus zero right I'd rather you know
that second billion doesn't count as
much to me and and similarly you're
saying the
happiness of the billionaires in society
counts less to you than the happiness of
the less well-law of people that's right
that's right
not
count less because money can buy them
less things
it's that even taking into account
um
how much well-being each bit of money
can give you we should care more about
the worst off and one word I'm sorry go
ahead one worry about rolls's theory is
that it's literally the single worst off
person who is is running things so even
if you have a hundred million very happy
middle class people if there's one
person who's really suffering then
that's no good in his theory and you're
happy you're much more
willing to put up with that in some
sense
uh I'm
going to put up my my
I will put up with
someone some one person being a lot more
poorly off if it gets a sufficient
number of people a sufficiently amount
better off I mean on the one hand I I
has anything like rolls's Criterion ever
come close to being implemented in any
world like have we ever had a society
that really tried to maximize things for
the worst off person anyway
now pretty much not
um but okay but again you've introduced
sort of a new degree of Freedom right I
mean so you're saying yes I want to have
a distribution that is that is skewed in
some way about caring about people's
welfare
what what's the right one to use is
there a way to answer that
good question
um
so
between individuals
and
societal well-being as harsany and Rawls
do
I want to think about what principles
should we use when making decisions for
other people and that'll hopefully help
us figure out
um what we should do in in this case so
I think when making decisions for other
people we
we are uh as risk-averse as it's
reasonable to be so we have these sort
of ideas like don't take a risk for
someone else unless you know they
approve it or something like that so if
we if we can think about uh how
risk-averse it's reasonable to be
um in other words how much weight could
we reasonably put on say the bottom 10
of our distribution whatever number that
is we're going to end up putting that
much weight on the worst off 10 in
society okay so it does kind of fit
together nicely that is the idea yeah
yeah exactly and and since you published
this does everyone say oh yes she's
completely right we agree or there's
still critics out there who think
absolutely everyone thinks I'm right
that's good okay if we could imagine
hypothetically someone might want to
disagree like well what would the cup
what would the criticism be
yeah so are you thinking of uh they're
different kinds of criticisms both for
the decision Theory and for the
social the theory about societal
distribution for the decision Theory
let's let's for the decision Theory yeah
um
so a lot of the way this kind of debate
goes is that
um there are these popular arguments in
favor of expected utility maximization
and I try to show none of them work they
just end up with some weaker uh
principle
like I told you the argument about
um how things would go if we were to
repeat the decision over and over again
I think that's not a good argument for
expected utility maximization uh because
we're not always going to repeat
decisions over and over again so all the
arguments in my against my view are sort
of of that vein and one argument uh
which I think is pretty interesting is
about how people who are risk avoidant
in my sense
uh will behave across time
and how they'll respond to information
so I mentioned earlier in the podcast
that if you're an expected utility
maximizer you're always going to want to
make decisions on the basis of more
information rather than
but if you're a risk-weighted expected
utility maximizer which is what I call
people who follow my view then sometimes
you're going to prefer uh to make a
decision with the information you have
rather than to get more information oh
and some people think
that shows that
uh risk-weighted expected utility
maximizers are irrational right some
people yeah well it's like a it's just a
a
theorem of rationality that make
decisions on more information rather
well it
can you give an example of where more
information I mean is it more
information is just not helpful or is it
actively harmful well the basic idea is
that when you're getting more
information
it's often not a information directly
up that tells you what's true in the
case of your decision so for example
uh if you could if you were thinking
about taking a coin flip and you could
get information about whether the coin
would lands heads or tails that's always
going to be good but there's gonna be
some cases in which
um information will talk you out of
taking a risk that would have been a
good risk to take okay uh and those are
the examples in which the risk avoiding
person is not going to do better with
more information so in particular you
already have a a high probability that
the course of action you're thinking
about will work
um and you're considering getting
information that might
put you into a state where you're like
50 50 about whether it will work you're
not like sure it'll work you're not sure
it won't work
um
those are going to be the kinds of cases
in which the risk avoidant person isn't
going to want more information but your
attitude is that there's no
incompatibility between not wanting more
information and still being rational
that's right yeah that's right my
attitude is it's sort of the more basic
question is
how should we take risk into account in
decision making and then it's going to
be an interesting upshot of our theory
of the true theory weather information
is always good or whether it's sometimes
bad whereas my critics might say no it's
part of the data that information should
always be good
so however we take risk into account we
want our theory about that to respect
this datum so maybe for the final
question uh has thinking about risk and
rationality in this way changed your own
way of thinking about risks or should it
change anyone's way or is it merely a
way of sort of reassuring yourselves
that we're being rational yeah yeah
great question
so
two and two things I want to say and one
is how we should think about ourselves
and what is how we should think about
other people so uh I got into decision
Theory as I mentioned because I'm really
bad at making decisions I hope there
would be some mathematical theory that
would just tell me what to do straighten
everything out all of that
um after exploring the question of how
to take risk into account it turns out
that even more is up to me than I
thought
um so uh the sort of upshot of that
is that there's this additional thing
that I have to think hard about which is
do I want to be the kind of person that
sort of like does pretty well no matter
what or do I want to be the kind of
person
uh that goes for things where things
might turn out amazing but night might
turn out horribly
um that's something you might have to
think about when you choose a job it's
maybe something you have to think about
when you choose a romantic partner or a
place to live
um so the upshot is like that's going to
be a feature of you that you have to set
and there's like no right and wrong way
to set it uh you know the sort of the
Romantic that's like as long as there's
a chance I want to go for it it's doing
something fine and the sort of cautious
person that's like no no I just want to
make sure things go better no matter
what it's also doing something fine so
that's the sort of personal upshot
um the upshot for how we think about
other people
um is that this is like an additional
fact that might vary between people and
just to put it in more concrete terms uh
when during covid there were all these
arguments about what restrictions we
should have for example
um
should we go out to restaurants or not
that was like a question people
disagreed about and one thing I noticed
is that when people disagreed they often
thought the other person had really
different values from them so oh you
want to go out to restaurants because
you don't care about Grandparents you
want grandparents to die that's why you
want to go to restaurants on the other
hand you have the person who
um didn't think we should have a lot of
restrictions saying something like well
you don't care about friendship you
don't care about people's livelihoods
you just want people to like be lonely
and not
um not have their jobs right so like
they thought of each other as having
different values in decision Theory
terms we would say as having different
utility functions
um but if you notice that people can
have different attitudes towards risk
that don't show up in the utility
function you could sort of think
actually these people had shared values
everybody
doesn't want grandparents to die
everybody cares about that everybody
cares about each other's work each
other's relationships and so forth It's
just that one group of people was
weighing worse scenarios a lot more
heavily than the other so in fact they
were both being rational in their
preferences and they were both
responding to the right values it's just
that they had
um these different risk attitudes and
now maybe it's a separate question of
given that how that people have
different risk attitudes what should we
do but
in making rules for all of us but the
first thing is to realize that somebody
might want to do things differently than
you in one of these risky cases without
having different values from you is this
is this like one of the Big Five
personality traits or something like
that
let's make it
the risk attitude attitude number six
all right that's good we have a program
going forward that was very very helpful
so Lara bushek thanks so much for being
on the blindscape podcast thank
[Music]